- It turns out having a cut body
doesn't always cut it with the ladies.
- I can lift twice my own weight
but ladies don't like that.
- Hi! Hey! Hi! Hey! Hi!
I'm fitness celebrity Rob Dod. Rob Dod.
I'm gonna show you, you!
Yeah!
How to get a Rob Dod rad dad bod. Get it!
Hey! Hey! Hey! You wanna
get that rad dad bod
but you don't really wanna be a Dad?
- How do I get the rad dad bod?
- Hey! Hey! Hey! You see a
dad walking down the street.
Check out that rad dad bad
bod, I want one of those.
- How do I get one of
those sweet dad bods?
- Hey! Hey! Hey! How do
you get that rad dad bod?
You wanna get that rad
dad bod? You wanna get it?
- How do I get that super awesome dad bod?
- Get it! Get it! Get it!
Get it! You wanna get it?
- How do I get that super awesome dad bod?
- Get it! Get it! Get it! Check out
these Rob Dod rad dad bod
repeatable workout routines.
- I'm Rob Dod's brother Todd Dob.
I'm here to show you
Rob Dod's dad bod move.
Burger flip. Kick it.
Dad jokes. Your old man
can be funny, here we go.
The beer drink.
Cool.
The stand when your team wins.
Yeah. Yeah.
The baby carry, and cuddle and cuddle.
What?
Sizing up a problem and doing nothing.
(upbeat playful music)
Get excited. Reading kids a bedtime story.
- Don't take my word for it.
Don't take my word for it.
Straight from the horse's mouth.
Check out these testimonials.
Check, check, check them out.
Check them out. Check
them out. Check them out.
- I used to think I had
to work out to be sexy
but now I know I don't have to.
Thanks Rob Dod's rad dad bods.
- I used to be a virgin but
now I've been on a date.
Thanks Rob Dod rad dad bods.
- To get Rob Dod's rad dad
bod call the number below.
Whoa! Check it out.
Call that number.
- Okay, but how do I get a Mom bod?
- You push out a kid.
- Ugh! That seems a lot harder
than what they're doing.
- Yeah. This is just laziness.
- And poor outfit choices.
- [Todd] Remember to sit
and drink for ten minutes.
(old school dance music)
- Hey guys, when do you think
big bands are coming back?
(old school dance music)